- I am someone who loves
warm exchanges with people.
I smile at everyone.
It's important to me.
And I worry all the time
about the new normal
of wearing masks,
because it's hard to tell what everyone
around us is feeling and communicating.
And our next guest is an expert
at communicating all of that
and more with just her gorgeous eyes.
Please welcome the entrepreneurial maven
and creator of smizing, Tyra Banks.
(audience cheering)
(Drew clapping)
Oh, my God, you're here.
- I am here.
Hi, Drew.
It's so good to see you.
- Oh, hi Tyra.
I love you so much for so many reasons.
At the top of the list,
I wanted to see if you could come here
and be the authority
on letting us all know
if it's going to be okay,
and people are going to know
that we're smizing at them,
how to smize.
Teach us, guru.
- I got you, Drew.
I got you.
How many times have you been
just out and about walking
and you have on your mask,
and you think somebody is being
really mean to you or rude?
And it's not that they are,
it's just that they're smiling
with their mouth
and not with their eyes,
so they just look evil.
So it's important, yes, Drew,
but you see, yeah.
They're doing that, they're doing that.
Ah!
And so we have to smile with our eyes,
and I created smizing really just
about having an intense
look at a gaze in a photo.
I never thought in a million years
that it would mean so much more
and come to me in so much more
and be so important today
with us wearing masks.
And so I always say in order
to get the right smize,
you have to think of
something that delights you.
What delights you, Drew?
- My daughters make me smize.
- Oh, okay, okay, then I want you to think
about your daughters,
and I want you to think about
they're doing something.
Okay, say they are performing on a stage
and you're in the audience.
Oh yeah, there you go, Drew.
You're in the audience,
they're performing on the stage
and you are so proud of them,
and you want to beam that
light from your being into them
because you are so proud.
And what happens is your
eyes begin to squint,
your mouth becomes slightly numb,
and all the energy comes up here,
and you're like, yeah, baby.
Yes, and so now a smize
doesnt just mean I'm fierce.
A smize today means thank you,
or a smize means you go first,
or a smize means I'm going to be here
for you during this difficult time
that you are going through right now.
So it means so much,
and so it's so important
to use these muscles here
and not just the muscles here.
- I thought, who could be
someone that I could turn to
to show the kind of communications,
the feelings I want to
convey, the goodness.
You are who came to mind.
You are an entrepreneur.
You make it happen.
You have ice cream, by
the way, SMiZE Cream!
- Yes, I'm launching SMiZE Cream, Drew,
and it is all natural,
super premium ice cream.
Inside of every serving of SMiZE Cream
is an edible trufflelicious
cookie dough surprise.
And you have to search, dig, and find it.
So it's like gamification,
and it's all natural,
and it's all good
tasting.
- See, that's what I'm talking
about, you just said gamification.
You are such a smart businesswoman,
and thank you for being someone
that I could emotionally
summon in the universe
as someone to turn to in these times
to show the love in the right way.
- You are welcome, and
you're one of those people
to me that I'm like,
"Why are we not friends?"
- By the way,
I'm in.
I'm so in.
- Isn't that weird?
I'm in too.
I am going to give my number
to your people after this
'cause I'm like, "She's an entrepreneur.
I'm an entrepreneur.
I had a talk show.
She has a talk show.
We're both bad ass bitches."
- Well, as they say at
the end of "Casablanca",
"This is the beginning of a
long and beautiful friendship."
I'm in.
- I'm so in, too.
This is so weird, people
are going to be like,
"Oh my God, they're friends right now.
I saw it happen."
- Tyra Banks, Mondays on ABC
with "Dancing with the Stars",
SMiZE Cream, smizing,
entrepreneur, leader, rebel.
- And new friend.
- And my new friend, Tyra Banks!
(Drew imitating explosion)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)